- My favorite fast food fries
are hands down McDonalds.
- Burger King.
- Five Guys.
- McDonalds or In-n-Out
are like the top two.
Hands down.
- It's good but it's
not like mind blowing.
- Yeah it's a little soggy.
- A flavor reminiscent of a fried Q-Tip.
- There's no salt on it
so there's no seasoning.
- There are certain fries that can
stand alone without ketchup,
these are not those fries.
- Mmm.
- McDonalds.
- Fluffy, salty, definitely McDonalds.
- Taking a bite of one
is like taking a bite
of my entire childhood
and the America flag.
- It's like a french fry that
you would make out of Playdoh.
Plastic surgery fry.
- It's had a little cosmetic surgery.
- They just taste exactly
what a fry should taste like.
- No! That's not Five Guys!
- It's gotta be Five Guys!
- So good!
- This are good, these are
like gourmet fast food fries.
- It's clearly a potato.
It's like this is fresh from the farm.
- What fries are these?
- That's gotta be Five Guys.
- Yeah that's Five Guys.
- Ew, ew, ew, ew, ew, ew.
- There's a flavor here that I'm detecting
that's unlike any other
fry flavor I've ever had.
- Dude this smells like paint.
- These look like reject fries.
Like they're discount fries.
- That's not a french fry.
- That's disgusting.
- I don't even know what it is.
- I'm finishing it, it's so gross.
- These are interesting.
- These are like diner fries.
- These taste like bowling alley fries.
- Oh no no, that...
- Mmm.
- has a weird, there's another flavor.
- Burger King! Whaddup?
Best fries ever!
- This is very good but it has a taste.
- Seasoned to perfection.
- I'm into these.
- I'm really into these.
- Yeah this is winning for sure.
- That's a very long french fry.
- I've had these fries, I don't know
where they're from though.
- These almost taste like popcorn.
- Seasoned enough.
- That's nice.
Old Burger King.
- These taste like fries made by a place
that doesn't normally make fries.
- Alright, I'm going to go
with Carl's Jr. on this one
I think they like, revamped their fries.
- Burger King.
- Oh Burger King, yes.
- It's got a little bit of crunch.
A little bit of sogginess to it.
- Crunchy on the outside,
smooth on the inside.
Just like me.
- Burger King french with McDonalds.
- That's like incest.
- Are you saving these for anyone else,
or can I just eat them all?
- I mean this is a great
day like I just came to work
and now I'm eating french fries.